we would be really lucky to have have a
family you know congratulations are in
order
Amy Schumer is officially a mom if you
had a good pregnancy like appear someone
who enjoyed being pregnant I just hope
your car flips over that's what I wish
for you all jokes aside the comedian and
her hubby chef Chris Fisher welcomed
their first child together you don't
stop be you you know you don't stop
working or drinking like you amy has
definitely not stopped being herself
posting hilarious videos and photos to
Instagram throughout her pregnancy and
teased fans about the baby's gender role
and rhinos was the baby's gender
which we're so excited to say that we
don't care what the gender is the 37
year old actress was also very candid
about the difficulties of being pregnant
revealing she suffered from hyperemesis
a pregnancy complication that causes
extreme nausea exhaustion and
dehydration I didn't know the
pregnancies could be such a bummer I
threw up a bunch of time so may we hear
the couple's bundle of joy arrived
shortly after the pair celebrated their
first year of marriage but rumors about
Amy being pregnant began shortly after
she and Fisher tied the knot in a
private ceremony in Malibu California in
February 2018 after just a few months of
dating hours after sharing the happy
news the I feel pretty star addressed
the speculation as to why she and Fisher
decided to walk down the aisle so soon
riding on social media quote no I am not
pregnant the pair exchanged vows in
front of close family and friends
including Jennifer Aniston Jake
Gyllenhaal Chelsea Handler and Jennifer
Lawrence I mean it was beautiful it was
you know very sudden but it was I mean
it was just I was sobbing though his
vows were stunning but it's just been
two people really love each other and
they really mean it it shows and it's
it's it was a beautiful ceremony and an
amazing time it was great I mean I
couldn't be happier for Amy recently
opened up about her hubby's autism
spectrum diagnosis in her new Netflix
comedy special Amy Schumer growing all
of the reasons that I fell madly in love
with him that's the truth
he says whatever is on his mind sharing
the inspirational reason why she chose
to talk about the diagnosis to Seth
Meyers
in March we both wanted to talk about it
because it's been totally positive I
think a lot of people resist getting
diagnosed and even with some of their
children because of the stigma that
comes along with it but you're not just
diagnosed and then they throw you out
like you know hopefully if you can get
help like the tools that we've been
given have made his life so much better
in our marriage and our life more
manageable and so I just wanted to you
know encourage people to not be afraid
of that stigma